-♪ (SUSPENSEFUL MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
-NARRATOR:
(PHONE VIBRATES)
The president's losing
a Twitter fight to Jewel.
NARRATOR:
-(PHONE VIBRATES)
-ISIS won Powerball?
Who sold them a ticket?
-NARRATOR:
-(PHONE VIBRATES)
Where are kittens
even getting opioids?
-(PHONE VIBRATES)
-Oh, he did the accent.
It's much more racist
if he did the accent.
-(PHONE VIBRATES)
-A chipmunk
attacked a synagogue...
and he knew it was a synagogue.
-♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
-NARRATOR:
-(PHONE VIBRATES)
-Wait, Harambe, again?
I literally don't understand
how that's possible.
Did he come back?
And then they got him again?
Was the same kid involved?
NARRATOR:
(PHONE VIBRATES)
This one just says, "Run!"
-♪ (THEME MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
-NARRATOR:
NARRATOR: ...returns Sunday,
February 18th on HBO.
(JOHN YELLING)